joining me now David shown former Trump
impeachment lawyer David I know you were
covering this and watching this closely
and getting reports as it was happening
um I want to remind viewers that this is
not a jury trial for the life of me I
don't understand why they didn't request
a jury but in a situation like this when
the judge said that he does not want to
hear what Trump has to say what does
that signal yeah I mean let's make that
very clear the judge explicitly said I
don't want to hear what he has to say
that probably epitomizes the Sham that
this whole thing is I think of all of
the cases against President Trump and uh
they're pretty good candidates for this
uh this one is the most offensive at
least right now to most people this is a
case in which there are no losses no
victims it allows a partisan attorney
general who ran on a platform of getting
Trump which itself was ethically
problematic um uh it allows now a judge
as you say without a jury to determine
that he is going to take away try to
take away president Trump business
licenses in New York state take away
valuable properties with again no losses
no victims it's a sham but today we
heard it this case seems to be all about
this judge we learned today that he has
a section in the courtroom reserved for
his friends and his law Clerk's friends
to come and watch it's a circus to him
um but you know I would imagine the poll
numbers went way up after today because
what president Trump did was stand up to
this judge like I think every American
would like to do in a justice system and
usually a lawyer says now listen you
can't talk to a judge that way you know
after all this guy's deciding the case
but president Trump is very Savvy and he
knows that this judge has already
decided this case and so he said he
called it like it was he didn't ask to
be there he didn't ask for this case to
be brought and if you're going to bring
him there you're not going to bully him
and you must listen to what he has to
say or you're making it more of a sham
and a horrible reflection on the
Integrity of our Judicial System well
David speaking of the judge I want to
play um a CNN report from inside the
courtroom watch
after Trump testified his lawyer signal
to the judge that there are still some
motions that they would like to file
they would like to file a motion for a
mistrial and there were also some issues
that they want to raise related to the
gag order the judge encouraged them not
to file any such motion and then said
that he was ordering them not to file
that motion she was obviously outside
the courthouse but the judge apparently
backed down from that order David but to
initially deny any motion
just out of hand without even seeing the
Motions uh that was risking what a
motion for a mistrial or more mo more
you know grounds for the appeal that's
obviously going to come right certainly
grounds for the appeal I mean it's as if
he's going out of his way to show the
American public that he runs a sham
courtroom it's horrible as a lawyer I
can tell you you know we all have a
vested interest in seeing that the
justice system operates properly he
never should have allowed this attorney
general to bring this act action it
should have been dismissed as a matter
of first course the law is
extraordinarily broad this executive law
that permits this in this case you know
you mentioned earlier about a jury trial
it happens that this executive law
there's a case construing it that says
there's no right to a jury trial in my
view his lawyers still should have asked
ran to preserve the record because in
this case it goes far beyond injunctive
relief to really uh excessive damages if
they really intend to find him $250
million and take away his business and
all of that God forbid that should ever
be upheld by any Court even a court in
New York yeah I would have made the
motion as well uh on the jury trial
David great to see you thank you so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else